noch nie ist das meereseis im herbst
geschmolzen und zurückgegangen dieses
jahr ist das aber zum ersten mal der
fall
die erde scheint sich nicht mehr erholen
zu können
vom klimawandel jetzt bei klick zum
science fiction am ersten september 2016
begann aus meteorologischer sicht der
herbst für klima und umwelt forscher ist
der herbstanfang ein wichtiger
referenzpunkt im herbst sollte nämlich
folgendes passieren
die temperatur in der arktis also in der
nähe des nordpols fällt auf bis zu minus
25 grad und die über das jahr verteilt
geschmolzen eisflächen wachsen wieder
auf mehrere millionen quadratkilometer
an
soweit zur theorie in der praxis sieht
das experten des national snow and ice
data data centers zufolge dieses jahr
ganz anders aus aktuelle fehle noch eine
million quadratkilometer meeres eis um
wachstumsprognosen unter normalen
umständen gerecht zu werden normal ist
aber schon lange kein maßstab mehr
schaut man sich den verlauf der letzten
37 jahre an im jahr das hat 78 starteten
die ersten satelliten gestützten
messungen des meeres ist das wiederum
nicht verwunderlich ein stetiger und
nicht gerade leichter abwärtstrend
scheint kein ende zu nehmen
der grund dafür ist wenn man sich diese
grafik anschaut eigentlich ganz klar die
durchschnittstemperatur wurde im oktober
2016 weit bis zu acht grad celsius
überschritten im darauffolgenden monat
also jetzt im monat november wurde es
bitter wird es noch schlimmer in einigen
regionen betrug die lufttemperatur null
grad celsius anstatt der sonst
vorherrschenden minus 20 grad celsius
überträgt man das auf deutschland wäre
draußen gerade jetzt hochsommer
neben der entwicklung des arktischen
meeres sorgt auch die datenanalyse
deckel global mehr als flächen für
entsetzen
wie man das hier in roth sieht setzt
sich das aktuelle jahr weit von den
anderen jahren ab bzw
verläuft komplett anders die
meereseisfläche sinkt immer weiter nach
unten und steigt nicht wie die anderen
jahre an dieses jahr haben wir also wohl
tatsächlich einen neuen negativrekord
aufgestellt die basis der aktiven
eisflächen verschwindet und kann sich
nicht erholen die antarktis dagegen
scheint davon nichts mitzubekommen
obwohl es dort wärmer als sonst ist kann
man keinen auffälligen schwund
feststellen warum das weiß aktuell
keiner so recht der wandel der
arktischen eisflächen reicht aber
eigentlich schon aus um zu sehen dass
etwas nicht stimmt zitat aufgrund der
großen antarktischen variabilität ist
die globale meeres als fläche nicht
besonders aussagekräftig die langfristig
zu beobachtende meereseis abnahme in der
arktis hingegen schon berichtet lars
kaleschke von der universität hamburg
was bedeutet das für uns erstmal
bedeutet dass wir dürfen diese
veränderungen nicht verharmlosen oder
einfach wieder vergessen einer der
punkte des klimavertrags der 2020 in
kraft treten soll ist zitat die staaten
setzten sich das ziel die erderwärmung
im vergleich zum vorindustriellen
zeitalter auf weit unter zwei grad
celsius zu beschränken es sollen
anstrengungen unternommen werden den
temperaturanstieg bereits bei 15 grad zu
stoppen
das klingt nach den eben genannten
zahlen eigentlich nicht mehr realistisch
und das ist sehr traurig ja wie es eben
noch bei der unterzeichnung des
vertrages sich angehört hat und wir hier
in europa wir sind ja ganz die strander
arktis also für uns könnte es die
stärksten konsequenzen bedeuten was
meint ihr wird der klimavertrag etwas
verändern oder sind die geplanten
maßnahmen ja kommen die viel zu spät um
die derzeitige entwicklung noch in den
griff zu bekommen diskutiertes unten in
den kommentaren ich bin auch dabei und
wenn euch das video gefallen hat dann
lass mir gerne einen daumen nach oben da
und ein kostenloses abo dafür einfach
klicken und wenn er hier klickt dann
kommt ihr zu einem video in dem wir uns
genauer mit dem klimavertrag
beschäftigen viel spaß dabei und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt